What is a Tesla bulb for a rifle machine?
So a Tesla bulb is just another name for a gas-filled tube.
So, with using rifle frequencies,
my definition of rifle,
because anybody can define it anyway in a wallet,
because there's no standard.
It's just using somebody's name.
But my definition of a rifle machine is using light frequencies.
And you use light frequencies through a frequency generator
by using a Tesla tube or a gas-filled tube, same thing.
So, that's what it is.
So, with the true rifle, which is the machine we use,
you're using the bulbs that are all sealed gas-filled tubes.
So, the frequencies are going through there.
And you're getting the frequencies through that light.
So, that's what dispersive it sees is the light.
So, it's not electrical frequencies.
It's light frequencies.
And that's my definition of a rifle machine.